Sociologist Zeynep Tufekci once said
that history is full of massive examples
of harm caused by people with great power
who felt that just because they felt
themselves to have good intentions,
that they could not cause harm.
In 2017,
Rohingya refugees started
to flee Myanmar into Bangladesh
due to a crackdown
by the Myanmar military,
an act that the UN subsequently
called of genocidal intent.
As they started to arrive into camps,
they had to register
for a range of services.
One of this was to register
for a government-backed
digital biometric identification card.
They weren't actually given
the option to opt out.
In 2021, Human Rights Watch accused
international humanitarian agencies
of sharing improperly collected
information about Rohingya refugees
with the Myanmar government
without appropriate consent.
The information shared
didn't just contain biometrics.
It contained information
about family makeup, relatives overseas,
where they were originally from.
Sparking fears of retaliation
by the Myanmar government,
some went into hiding.
Targeted identification
of persecuted peoples
has long been a tactic
of genocidal regimes.
But now that data is digitized,
meaning it is faster to access,
quicker to scale
and more readily accessible.
This was a failure
on a multitude of fronts:
institutional, governance, moral.
I have spent 15 years of my career
working in humanitarian aid.
From Rwanda to Afghanistan.
What is humanitarian aid, you might ask?
In its simplest terms,
it's the provision of emergency care
to those that need it the most
at desperate times.
Post-disaster, during a crisis.
Food, water, shelter.
I have worked within
very large humanitarian organizations,
whether that's leading
multicountry global programs
to designing drone innovations
for disaster management
across small island states.
I have sat with communities
in the most fragile of contexts,
where conversations about the future
are the first ones they've ever had.
And I have designed global strategies
to prepare humanitarian organizations
for these same futures.
And the one thing I can say
is that humanitarians,
we have embraced digitalization
at an incredible speed
over the last decade,
moving from tents and water cans,
which we still use, by the way,
to AI, big data, drones, biometrics.
These might seem
relevant, logical, needed,
even sexy to technology enthusiasts.
But what it actually is,
is the deployment of untested technologies
on vulnerable populations
without appropriate consent.
And this gives me pause.
I pause because the agonies
we are facing today
as a global humanity
didn't just happen overnight.
They happened as a result
of our shared history of colonialism
and humanitarian technology innovations
are inherently colonial,
often designed for
and in the good of groups of people
seen as outside of technology themselves,
and often not legitimately recognized
as being able to provide
for their own solutions.
And so, as a humanitarian myself,
I ask this question:
in our quest to do good in the world,
how can we ensure that we do not
lock people into future harm,
future indebtedness and future inequity
as a result of these actions?
It is why I now study the ethics
of humanitarian tech innovation.
And this isn't just
an intellectually curious pursuit.
It's a deeply personal one.
Driven by the belief that it is often
people that look like me,
that come from
the communities I come from,
historically excluded and marginalized,
that are often spoken on behalf of
and denied voice in terms of the choices
available to us for our future.
As I stand here on the shoulders
of all those that have come before me
and in obligation for all of those
that will come after me
to say to you that good intentions alone
do not prevent harm,
and good intentions alone can cause harm.
I'm often asked, what do I see
ahead of us in this next 21st century?
And if I had to sum it up:
of deep uncertainty,
a dying planet, distrust, pain.
And in times of great volatility,
we as human beings, we yearn for a balm.
And digital futures
are exactly that, a balm.
We look at it in all of its possibility
as if it could soothe all that ails us,
like a logical inevitability.
In recent years,
reports have started to flag
the new types of risks that are emerging
about technology innovations.
One of this is around how data collected
on vulnerable individuals
can actually be used
against them as retaliation,
posing greater risk not just against them,
but against their families,
against their community.
We saw these risks
become a truth with the Rohingya.
And very, very recently, in August 2021,
as Afghanistan fell to the Taliban,
it also came to light
that biometric data collected on Afghans
by the US military
and the Afghan government
and used by a variety of actors
were now in the hands of the Taliban.
Journalists' houses were searched.
Afghans desperately raced against time
to erase their digital history online.
Technologies of empowerment then become
technologies of disempowerment.
It is because these technologies
are designed on a certain set
of societal assumptions,
embedded in market and then filtered
through capitalist considerations.
But technologies created in one context
and then parachuted into another
will always fail
because it is based on assumptions
of how people lead their lives.
And whilst here, you and I
may be relatively comfortable
providing a fingertip scan
to perhaps go to the movies,
we cannot extrapolate that out
to the level of safety one would feel
while standing in line,
having to give up that little bit
of data about themselves
in order to access food rations.
Humanitarians assume
that technology will liberate humanity,
but without any due consideration
of issues of power, exploitation and harm
that can occur for this to happen.
Instead, we rush to solutionizing,
a form of magical thinking
that assumes that just
by deploying shiny solutions,
we can solve the problem in front of us
without any real analysis
of underlying realities.
These are tools at the end of the day,
and tools, like a chef's knife,
in the hands of some,
the creator of a beautiful meal,
and in the hands of others, devastation.
So how do we ensure that we do not design
the inequities of our past
into our digital futures?
And I want to be clear about one thing.
I'm not anti-tech. I am anti-dumb tech.
(Laughter)
(Applause)
The limited imaginings of the few
should not colonize
the radical re-imaginings of the many.
So how then do we ensure
that we design an ethical baseline,
so that the liberation that this promises
is not just for a privileged few,
but for all of us?
There are a few examples
that can point to a way forward.
I love the work of Indigenous AI
that instead of drawing
from Western values and philosophies,
it draws from Indigenous
protocols and values
to embed into AI code.
I also really love the work of Nia Tero,
an Indigenous co-led organization
that works with Indigenous communities
to map their own well-being
and territories
as opposed to other people
coming in to do it on their behalf.
I've learned a lot from the Satellite
Sentinel Project back in 2010,
which is a slightly different example.
The project started essentially
to map atrocities
through remote sensing
technologies, satellites,
in order to be able to predict
and potentially prevent them.
Now the project wound down
after a few years
for a variety of reasons,
one of which being that it couldn’t
actually generate action.
But the second, and probably
the most important,
was that the team realized they
were operating without an ethical net.
And without ethical guidelines in place,
it was a very wide
open line of questioning
about whether what they were doing
was helpful or harmful.
And so they decided to wind down
before creating harm.
In the absence of legally binding
ethical frameworks
to guide our work,
I have been working
on a range of ethical principles
to help inform
humanitarian tech innovation,
and I'd like to put forward
a few of these here for you today.
One: Ask.
Which groups of humans
will be harmed by this and when?
Assess: Who does this solution
actually benefit?
Interrogate: Was appropriate consent
obtained from the end users?
Consider: What must we
gracefully exit out of
to be fit for these futures?
And imagine: What future good
might we foreclose
if we implemented this action today?
We are accountable
for the futures that we create.
We cannot absolve ourselves
of the responsibilities
and accountabilities of our actions
if our actions actually cause harm
to those that we purport
to protect and serve.
Another world is absolutely,
radically possible.
Thank you.
(Applause)